however this is an interesting area
because it's it's very creative to come
up with new algorithms there's often
many ways to solve the same problem but
unlike art say and algorithms they're
quantifiable measures for how good you
did what is the running time of the
thing you ended up with how much space
does it use is it efficient so it's nice
and that you can actually it's easy to
evaluate whether you kind of succeeded
did you get the n log n algorithm did
you get the fastest that's possible but
it's hard to measure students
understanding because it's like did you
get the creative trick that we had in
mind or find another one that's just as
good students may find a different
creative trick that doesn't end up with
as good an algorithm in the end so we
penalize that someone but for the most
part we are happy when people get
correct algorithms when they they
understand the techniques well enough
that they get an algorithm it's pretty
good it may not be the best but we
consider that much better than they hey
we're using the right technique but they
ended up using it wrong and so they end
up with something that doesn't even work
and that's that's much more discouraging
yes but in any case in a timed exam it's
really hard to expect students to be
creative so in that setting it's hard we
don't expect a lot of creativity we try
to keep the questions relatively simple
so you need just one simple idea if
you're familiar with the material it
should come quickly
it doesn't always fit so problem sets
are definitely an easier way for
students to express the creativity
gives them a little more time to think
about the problem because some problems
are gonna come easy to some students and
hard to others it's going to be
different each problem set so that gives
them they have a week to think about it
and also to talk to others we allow
collaboration in the problem sets so
that makes it a lot easier to find
solution but still learn learned a lot
from it in the exams it's a lot harder
in past years we've tried take-home
exams as a way to
more accurately gauge how creative
someone is in applying these techniques
to design new algorithms we didn't do
that this year it's not clear what the
right answer is it's definitely a
challenge in teaching algorithms is how
to evaluate whether someone can really
apply the techniques in new and creative
ways